what's happening you bad [ __ ]
it's wednesday
cinco the [ __ ] mayo
the joint is brought to you by blue
blocks listen i've already told you
about blue blocks amazing sleep mass
and now i'm here to tell you about their
light filtering glasses
they're [ __ ] tremendous you get any
style
color or size plus they got virtual
try on that is tremendous if you go on
their website
they have a web a virtual [ __ ] try on
i loved it
this is why i felt i fell in love with
this company first you got the sleep
plus the red lenses
for true blue and green light blocking
use that after sundown
if you have trouble sleeping or you get
anxious at night these
are for you then we got the clear blue
light
lens filter blue light during the day if
you spend all day in front of the
computer
this is for you cut down on headaches
and eye strain and finally summer glow
yellow lenses
color therapy for the winter blues
clinically plural
proven to lift your mood plus you get
all the benefits of blue light
blocking listen to me ever since i got
these glasses
and the mask sent to me my life has
changed i love this little sleep mask
think of how i felt the night after the
michael jackson t
when i put these little blue blocks
sleep mask on i couldn't see nothing
here nothing
it was tremendous i sleep like a baby
if you're on the computer all day these
glasses these tortoise shells
are tremendous cut down on your
headaches cut down on your eye strain
you don't have to put visine in your
eyes every hour on the hour
blue blocks is a science-based company
their lenses are made under optics
laboratory conditions in australia
you got a prescription no problem
they'll make it to your specifications
these are high quality lenses they're
not mass produced
and they come in a ton of different
styles from glasses to sleep masks
they got everything you might need for
light therapy
that service is great get them today the
website is great
i believe in these people these glasses
are tremendous i've been using these
since i got them at night
to watch look at the computer and you
know what i fall right to bed at night
no more headaches no more eye strain
support blue blocks because they support
the show
i'm gonna give you twenty percent off
with code joey at blueblocks.com
joey again that's blueblox.com
joey for 20 off that's b
l u b l o x dot com
slash joey use joey for 20
off if you guys don't mind it's time for
the joint
kick this [ __ ] where's my
lighter here oh
[ __ ] it's a beautiful day
to be alive
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
it's wednesday
cinco the [ __ ] mayo and i haven't
seen a mexican yet
you know what i'm saying it's [ __ ]
crazy i haven't seen no mexicans jumping
up and down
nothing i saw three mexicans across the
street mowing the lawn they didn't look
too [ __ ] happy so
it's not cinco de mayo in them by the
[ __ ] world you know what i'm saying
anyway it's a great day to be here great
week i've been [ __ ] taking care of
myself
uh i lost more weight i'm happy you
enjoyed the [ __ ] michael jackson tea
video
you [ __ ] went off the other
night that was one of the best teas
i ever made in all my life i slept
[ __ ] 10 hours
if you didn't notice i didn't post till
[ __ ]
10 30 in the morning and uh
it [ __ ] i slept i didn't fall asleep
for like an hour you
that night i played the guitar for a
while and i felt the effects coming over
me and i'm like [ __ ]
i am high as [ __ ] and i uh
i went [ __ ] for it last night i tamed
it down but something really weird
happened yesterday
i did not smoke pot all [ __ ]
day
that's the first time i have not smoked
pot
you probably have months no i have not
i haven't smoked pot today either so
that's the
that's the big thing i have not smoked
pot but i did those [ __ ] edibles the
other night for the team capsules and
the whole thing
yep three capsules in the whole [ __ ]
thing but it was uh
it was very [ __ ] tremendous man it
was a great night
and i do that you know i switch it up
every night because i love my [ __ ]
sleep i don't
wanna [ __ ] around so that's what puts me
to [ __ ] sleep
that's what i do that's what helps me
[ __ ] see the devil that's what i do
so i felt great
i'm happy you guys enjoyed the little
video i want to talk to you guys about
something today
that maybe you've been thinking about or
you haven't been thinking about
it's over that's it
we lost 15 months
of our [ __ ] life over covert did you
have you thought about that has this hit
you yet i mean july 1st everything opens
up in three states
no capacity do what the [ __ ] you want to
so that's it it's over that was it 15
[ __ ]
months i mean it was
a rough 15 months i mean i'm happy
listen
i always said even last april if you
listen to the old churches
i said that a lot of people
this was going to give a lot of people a
lot of time to think
lives are going to change careers were
going to change
obviously i didn't know i was talking
about me
you know i mean from the no drinking
espressos to the no smoking weed to the
you know to the anxiety medication i
mean i have gave up
all my you know i i was telling my wife
that one of my big
biggest [ __ ] fears was moving here
and just eating
hamburger deluxes just eating hamburger
deluxe just like a hamburger deluxe here
in jersey a cheeseburger deluxe is a
cheeseburger
with fries with gravy and mozzarella
cheese on it
so i thought i was gonna be eating three
or four dollars a [ __ ] week at night
pizza carvel well look at this so far
since i've been here
i've lost close to 35 [ __ ] pounds and
this is since the beginning of the
[ __ ] surgery
since i just applied myself but this
isn't what i'm talking about
i'm talking about how our lives changed
what i mean listen a lot of negatives
happened in your life during this
pandemic i understand
a lot of negatives happen in my life
also but think about all the positive
things that came from this
that you know you do your best work in
my world i do my best work
when i have a gun to my head and if this
pandemic wasn't a gun to your head
i don't know what was working from home
zooming
you know on the computer all [ __ ] day
whatever your life changed completely
you know
social distancing your desk you can't
breathe on people's necks casinos were
closed i mean
last night there was a point where
[ __ ] i felt so bad for degenerate
gamblers
i felt so bad because i know what it is
to have a habit i know what it is to
have a vice and to need it every day i
felt so bad when art
you couldn't bet on nothing but [ __ ]
bodies dying that's all you could bet on
there was one point where that was all
you were betting on how many people
gonna die on facetime today it was the
saddest
[ __ ] thing in the world but guess
what we push through it
we're here we're stronger because of it
i know a lot of you
are not in the place you want to be in
your life personally this took over your
[ __ ] life
but party look at listen for me it
changed my life completely
it let me know what i wanted to do what
i didn't want to do
and what i couldn't handle or handle
anymore and let me know i was burnt out
and let me know this is the best thing
that could happen
because now at least you know where the
[ __ ] you stand you know
my agents they don't call me every day
like they used to because i'm not going
on the road
so i don't need them no more all i said
you know you know
where you stand in this life when a
pandemic hits that's the best part about
this
it was like i told dalia after you know
the whole thing went down like at least
you know where you stand with other
comics with your friends
with bookers and everything like that
that's the best thing about life
sometimes
is knowing where the [ __ ] you stand and
i know where the [ __ ] i stand
you know i'm happier i see my daughter
she's
[ __ ] happy as [ __ ] my wife has her
own friends it's not people that want to
be her friend
because she's married to me and at the
end of the [ __ ] dinner
they whip out a script or they tell you
they want to [ __ ] come on the podcast
or something no the desperation
is gone from my life guys i don't even
want to do half the [ __ ]
you know i break everything down guys
i'm an overthinker
you know i don't really focus on a lot
of things but i look at them and i go
hmm
that's interesting a couple weeks ago
when i had those two auditions
listen i had a migraine for four
[ __ ] days i didn't know if it was the
johnson johnson shot
i didn't know if i had covered i didn't
know if i had a blood clot
i went for a blood test i did a bunch of
[ __ ] you know what that [ __ ]
migraine headache was fun those two
[ __ ] auditions
i did not want to put them on tape but i
went ahead and i did what i had to do
and then i
i remember saying that last line
and the headache went away i don't want
to be a part of that no more
it's so [ __ ] for right now for right
now for today
i am [ __ ] as happy as i can be
because
i'm living the life that i've been
wanting to for a long
[ __ ] time for years i told my agents
listen we gotta line up on the road a
little bit
you know i got a daughter i want to be
home more
i could not figure out how to get off
this [ __ ]
carousel i mean when i spoke to ali wong
a few weeks ago
she said the same thing we were on a
carousel that we could not get off of
all of us were in life
maybe you were in a bad relationship you
know whatever the [ __ ] you were doing
maybe you did a bunch of drugs during
the pandemic and you got clean you
started going to meetings
i have a couple guys on patreon that i
referred meetings to
because the pandemic was listen the
pandemic [ __ ] me up
[ __ ] me up completely i've never been
a listen
i do a job that is one of the toughest
jobs in the world
one of the [ __ ] hardest things of
life
if you look it up people what people are
scared of
the most is debt and fear of public
speaking
i do something that a lot of people
can't do for a living i don't
listen guys i don't have a lot of fear
about a lot of things i'm scared of
needles
i'm scared of [ __ ] like that but mostly
i'm pretty [ __ ] good you let me think
about something like the surgery you let
me think about something for a couple
weeks
i get pussified and then i go look at
you what are you a [ __ ] [ __ ] you
gotta get it together you [ __ ]
you need this [ __ ] knee surgery or
you need this blood test or you need
this covet [ __ ] shot i do what i have
to do
i'm not scared of anything this [ __ ]
you know when you started watching the
news in the beginning and they weren't
really telling you
everything it kind of [ __ ] me up a
little bit you saw it
you saw it in the podcasting you saw
when i first started the joint
and because of the joint and because of
patreon and because of the little things
i was doing
i've gotten better and better and better
and more confident
and here we are today am i confident
enough to do stand-up again i'm not in
the [ __ ] mood to get on the stage
i'm not in the mood to take [ __ ]
pictures i'm not in the mood to get the
ear beaten afterward
i'm just not in the [ __ ] mood i'll be
strictly honest with you [ __ ]
i'm getting into this [ __ ] girl
softball
i'm getting into this is the first time
it's like going fishing never go fishing
it's not about [ __ ] catching fish
it's about sitting on a lake
getting some sun and just being with
nature
it's just sitting outside and just
listening to the [ __ ] natural sound
the [ __ ] nature
and just going wow you know how lucky am
i to be able to do this
to come here and sit it's the same thing
when i go to girl softball
i'm watching her but at the same time
i'm sitting there in the [ __ ]
bleachers
uncomfortable nothing to lay back on you
know
and you're like what the [ __ ] am i doing
with my life i'm making a little girl's
[ __ ] day
and last time i checked that's what my
whole life is about is
every day you got to make somebody's day
you put a little smile on their face
doesn't mean you have to give them money
it doesn't mean you have to [ __ ]
eat their ass i'm talking about just
maybe a hello
just a smile maybe just a wink an
acknowledgement opening up a door for
somebody
maybe one of your buddies needs some
help [ __ ] uh
financially it's about that for me it's
always been about that for me because i
tell you what
every day somebody makes my [ __ ] day
at one point i go wow that was the
nicest thing through a message
or maybe through a [ __ ] gesture or
something i'm always
getting a great uh you know people are
always
want you know today i went to the gym
and i was doing a move and one of the
guys said to me joey it would work
better if you pulled it this way and
keep it low
tight you know he didn't have to do that
he didn't have to do that because your
elbow is sticking out make it a little
tighter
so when you pull it hits your lat
directly he didn't need to do that
he came over said to me did i tell him
to [ __ ] off no i go let me try it like
that i go oh i see what you're saying
i do feel the stretch now you know he
made my [ __ ] day
that's it did he give me money did he
give me a [ __ ] cheeseburger
did he have to give me a joint did he
have to give me weed no
none of those things he just did a
gesture and that's what i've been doing
throughout this whole thing
it's just a gesture sometimes it does
okay
sometimes it backfires but you know what
you feel better for doing it
and that's all that [ __ ] matters
especially now but you know what
it's over this pandemic is over that's
it
it's time to move on it's time to
[ __ ] get on with our [ __ ] lives
it's time to
you know make [ __ ] uh
grief you know somebody you lost
somebody during this it's time to really
work on it
it's just time we'll let let loose it's
it's i went to the shure last wednesday
i think me and my wife are going again
later on today you know we just
we're doing more things i'm happier and
i'm a different person stand up when i'm
ready
it's always going to be there it's
always going to be there when i'm ready
it'll be there chappelle took off for
years musicians take off for [ __ ]
years
and now people want to give me grief
because i want to take some time off
when i know it's time i'll be ready to
[ __ ] rock
between you and me guys i have been
writing a few jokes
are they [ __ ] lenny bruce no i'm not
writing no [ __ ] nothing brilliant but
at least
i'm putting my pen on the [ __ ] paper
do you understand what i'm trying to say
to you
so all i'm asking from you is just to
try that's it
i'm trying at least i'm playing the
guitar i'm trying to be a dad i'm
working out i'm [ __ ] walking
i've put walking therapy into my [ __ ]
regimen now
to make this knee tougher because the
muscle is kind of [ __ ] torn
and i'm just getting through it you know
my leg hurts but you don't hear me [ __ ]
about it i'm not on pain pills
i work at what i got i still go to the
gym i [ __ ] did
i am infatuated with my weight watcher
action points
i don't know if you guys know anything
about weight watchers you get 41 points
a day to eat
and then you get 44 if you go over those
41
as a reserve and then you have 61 points
that you have to exercise you're like
joey how do you exercise if you
ride the bike for a half hour
it's four points
you get four points and i don't put it
in the phone
will read google walk will [ __ ] put
it in
so right off the bat when i go in there
i ride the bike for
30 minutes that's four to five [ __ ]
points i leave my phone in my hooded
sweatshirt
while i work out because i'm walking so
i'll pull out six points out of there
if you work out with weights for 45
minutes
it's about 11 to 13 [ __ ] points
so every week i have to get to 61 points
for years i've been hitting 61 63
62 every [ __ ] week the last three
weeks
i've been hitting [ __ ] 70 71
74 i think last week was 74 and i didn't
work out
on saturday and sunday i did who guts i
walked
so i got like four points one day and i
got like four points the other
i was done with my points from lifting
on [ __ ] friday
so i've been infatuated with my [ __ ]
action points lately
you know you gotta ride the bike and
then i go for a [ __ ] walk
so if i could pull down eight points or
walking plus the 12
to 15 from lifting weights who you think
you're dealing with joey bananas
i'm looking good i'm looking smooth i'm
putting cbd lion cream on my face to get
away the [ __ ]
scars from my [ __ ] you to me picking
my face and scratching myself
it's a whole different life guys so i'm
very happy that this pandemic happened
i'm very happy that there's a light at
the end of the tunnel i mean
maybe i'm speaking too soon i don't want
to have to be like rogue and have to
come back and [ __ ]
retrace my [ __ ] words and say that
you know this [ __ ] in india is not good
so i don't know i'm not telling you not
to get back sonny i'm not saying none of
that [ __ ]
what i'm saying is that there's a light
at the end
of the [ __ ] tunnel right now whether
it backfires it doesn't backfire i don't
know they're opening everything up july
1st
so we're ready to go tip top magoo and i
congratulate you guys
i congratulate you guys for going
through this
we've exchanged emails we've changed
tweets over this
i knew a lot of you guys had a lot of
struggles during this uh
time frame but hey so far it's over
there's a [ __ ] end if you want to go
to work there's plenty of [ __ ] work
out there
ain't nobody going back because they're
getting the big [ __ ] 900
from unemployment i ain't stupid well if
you're giving me 900
and you want me to go back for a small
nickel go [ __ ] yourself i'm not going
back to work i'm staying at home
watching daytime television
playing with my [ __ ] chickens i ain't
mad at you i wouldn't go back but
eventually
you're gonna have to go back and
eventually you're gonna have to pay that
back there's gonna be a lot of
byte-aways
after this that we're not expecting so
get ready for the [ __ ] by the
ways
by the way we have a [ __ ] guest today
whether you like it or not i love this
guy
and uh we had a great chat because just
because i don't live in l.a
doesn't mean i don't miss my [ __ ]
friends i miss him
with all my heart i try to keep in touch
with him every week
two just i went back and forth with
birth today
and this gentleman that i just [ __ ]
is on the podcast today i just went back
and forth with him
i checked up on him so right now i bring
you
tom segura thank you for watching
tommy bunts hey what's up buddy what's
happening you bad [ __ ] you're
looking beautiful
thanks buddy what's happening how are
you chilling dog getting ready to move
it's crazy when is the move so i move
out of this house
on sunday and uh and then we go to a
hotel here for a week so we got to do
some more work in town
then we go to florida for a week and
visit family and then we fly to austin
so i'll be i'll be in a new house may
10th may
10th that one sold this one's not sold
yet i'm putting it on the market like
after we get out because they're gonna
they have to do paint and stage it and
everything but you know it'll it'll be
on sale in a couple weeks
you look good how are you feeling i feel
great man
what are you doing any therapy anything
nothing not really anymore i mean i have
my
workout like regimen that i go through
but i don't i don't have to do really pt
unless i
want to are there weird lines in here in
the back
behind you let me see if i
like you don't see weird lines in the
screen no oh okay you look beautiful
all right okay cool you miss burt um
you know i always miss burt i know you
miss bert huh
he's i miss all you guys i miss him i
miss not seeing you around but i mean
yeah i think bert's having a good time i
think it's going to be a really really
funny movie
i think you know we spoke a few weeks
ago then i talked to him on the phone
and
he's like i'm not drinking i'm trying to
i'm like that [ __ ]
that is so not true oh my god he's like
i'm not drinking in the daytime
there's a glass of wine i'm like
you he looked good you know he looked
we're all looking good
i mean uh yes and he he did um
because you know leading up to leaving
he was working out a lot
it was funny because he's like i'm
working out like six days a week and he
goes
i haven't i haven't not only not lost
weight i've gained weight
[Laughter]
and i was like how but then you just
know that he the way he eats and drinks
it's like there's no
he eats good what people don't
understand is that you eat well
yeah but you have no idea how much sugar
there is in alcohol
yeah you have no idea until you get off
alcohol
and then like now i don't drink i
haven't drank in years not because i'm
an a.a i just don't
i don't like the taste of it but there's
a little pizza ball around the corner
and i go in there for meatballs and
sausage you know my wife it's great
right like tonight after softball that
she's playing softball we'll go there
yeah and i always do a sangria i always
do a six-sided sangria
[ __ ] it's this big but it's six
weight watcher points
oh yeah man just for a little [ __ ]
glass so there's guys like him like he's
that
so like a lot of times whenever i'm like
fat and i'm trying to lose weight
people always like they don't know me
they'll be like you should cut back on
your drinking and i'm like yeah i don't
drink man
i mean i'm not totally sober but i don't
regularly drink and they're like oh
and i go that mentality would work
for like a bird like burt's the kind of
guy that if he was like
i'm not drinking for a month he'll lose
like 15 20 pounds
anybody will if you stop drinking if you
drink that much if you drink that much
yeah yeah yeah you know you guys all
forget
that my mother was a [ __ ] functioning
alcoholic
yeah and i saw her lose weight and put
on weight
you know she opened up with a heineken
with tomato juice
that's how it started who does that yeah
that's savagery
you know in the morning a budwei a
heineken
and tomato juice that was like her
appetizer
and then she's high functioning she's
running a business yeah she's running a
business she's thinking
she's numbers but i saw what a
functioning does but i saw when she
when she closed the bar she just
ballooned up
really that walking back and forth
behind the bar was a [ __ ] exercise
yeah you know eight ten hours of [ __ ]
night behind the ball yeah
once she stopped she ballooned up she
ended up in the hospital and they told
her to stop drinking
so i am like right now during this whole
pandemic
i got a couple confessions to make there
so we moved into this house september
1st
right first couple weeks i it was rough
i think i had like a mild heart attack
august 21st after i got here from
anxiety
just confusion frustration yeah
and uh i moved into the house and you
know
we we got into the community the whole
thing
and one afternoon without thinking you
know i started popping edibles in the
afternoon you know
30 here 100 here like i usually did like
my normal days in
la work yeah you know and
we went out to dinner with a family like
a bunch of families with kids
and i started nodding on the table like
[ __ ]
one of the kids was like are you okay
uncle joey and i'm like yeah i'm fine
and my wife said something to me she's
like you gotta cut it out now
we're in a new [ __ ] community and i
started thinking about it before i
started the podcast i'm like
i want the podcast to be different i
don't wanna you know you gotta come back
different
yeah so i'm not gonna smoke on the
podcast so that was rule number one do
you know
it is 1 30 1 45 here
and i have not smoked yet today no okay
all right
good man can you [ __ ] believe that no
so after my wife told me that that night
she's like joey you know you're your own
man but
you were [ __ ] high as [ __ ] at dinner
at the table
yeah so i stopped edibles
completely got off them did like a
45-day cleanse no no drinking nothing
you know i kept
whatever i just wanted to get my
tolerance down
yeah it was too out of control i mean
when i got when i had the surgery
those five milligrams oxycodone and i
don't even need oxycodone but they don't
do nothing to me
nothing nothing the five little fives
didn't do dictating
so i i cleaned up my whole life i turned
the edibles around
and now you know what i use the edibles
for to sleep that's the best
so i you're coming on team tom dude
that's what i do that's what you do
with that that's what i do what time do
you pick
what time do you pop them so if it's if
i'm doing it right
ideally i would like to do it like 90
minutes before i want to go to sleep
perfect that's that's the perfect time
because then you feel it
you get the buzz and you're like and if
it's you know if it's the right dosage
you're like oh yeah
you're watching something you start to
fade out go to bed
i actually i don't like taking it too
close to when i go to bed because then
i'm like i'm gonna
it messes it up i like it so if i want
to go to bed like at 11
you know i'll try to take it like 9 30.
i start my process at 9
30. yeah to sleep if i want to go to
sleep at 11 30
12. what does joey diaz need what dosage
do you do for going to sleep okay
so i experiment you know me i experiment
with everything i have you have to
experiment with yourself so
at nine o'clock once my daughter goes
upstairs
i come right down and i spray melatonin
in my throat
from on it i spray like 12 [ __ ]
sprays and then at 10
i come back down here and i'll take
kikimo
the tincture that two milligrams thc
but like five milligrams cbn
huh and i'll do like
five blast under my tongue like
tinctures
now cbd lion has
cbd cubes with melatonin in it
really so now i could add that to the
arsenal of sleep
so by by 10 o'clock i got melatonin in
me and the tincture
and then a quarter to 11 i go upstairs
because miami vice starts at 11.
i go upstairs and i [ __ ] make my
kikomoti
some nights i throw four capsules in
there like those the ones i gave you
yeah like i'll go [ __ ] 500 milligrams
drink it come down watch 10 minutes of
miami vice
then i'll practice the guitar okay
i'll practice the guitar i'll do all my
songs and
by the time i get to like [ __ ] uh
uh crazy train um i could feel the
edibles creeping up on me
i put the guitar back in the room i put
the pic in the drawer
and i walk right upstairs and it's
snappy [ __ ] noodle time nobody knows
dick and i sleep like a baby i sleep
till
8 15. wow so my daughter kisses me to
tell me she's leaving i get up with her
i throw some water on my face and i get
a cup of coffee i talk to her for like
10 minutes
and then it's off to school and that's
when my day starts
nice i go to the gym
two to three times a week i box once a
week here
um it's been all about health and mental
health
since i've been back here that's great i
had to get my mental back in touch
that la the last two years in l.a were a
little [ __ ] rocky man you know
for in many ways many ways nothing bad i
just
i don't think i was healthy uh
mental wise there was a lot of [ __ ]
going on with me i think there's a i
think it's not just you i think that i
mean i understand that but i think that
you know this city is a it's a weird
place man
and and you you kind of see that it's
kind of a
it's a strain it's a strange business
that we're in like that
that's a it's not the best thing
to be in la and in this business for
like you know good mental health i mean
it really can wear on you it does wear
on it wears on you it weighed up yeah it
went on me
i'm not proud to admit it but i'll admit
it you know it was just yeah
i think 2016 was my break point
after that i just became i was like numb
you know i needed
edibles just to function in my day i
needed
all this [ __ ] just to function you know
and then the pandemic came
and i started eating those [ __ ]
anxiety pills
i had had them stocked up for 12 years i
think i took like three of them
i would take them on the road to sleep
if i wanted to sleep good
and once the pandemic came i would wake
up with [ __ ] you know my anxiety
stopped when i woke up from the surgery
really january 9th i woke up and i'm
like wow
it disappeared because i had anxiety
about my heart i had anxiety about my
knee
moving here before the [ __ ] surgery
they did every test they could
you know like they did everything every
heart test
every test so i'm clear so i'm good so
when i woke up i lost like 50
of the anxiety then over the last couple
months
i've been getting better and better i
was struggling on stage tom
tom how long do you know me i was
struggling
struggling to go up there and say the
words so i
feel like you were feeling anxious about
that too yeah
once i cut that out of my life stand up
i
the anxiety 20 went away wow and once i
got the covers shot
i'm good now i'm still not jumping up
and down hanging out with people
yeah but i'm good i have my moments i go
to the gym
i make sure both doors are open you know
i wear my mask that's all you could do
that's all you could do
you know i'm the lightest i've been in
maybe
15 years wow that's great yeah i weighed
myself today i'm 18 pounds away from
my goal congrats my first goal you know
and uh a lot of people were inspired by
you when i had bert on a couple weeks
ago
he told me that what happened to you
really
wore on him like you were in good shape
you were healthy
and i think a lot of people saw that
fall and we all said [ __ ] it we're
getting strong
you know yeah man i mean it definitely
you know it was more mentally and
emotionally taxing than
a lot of people like a lot of people
were like
you broke your arm like what's the big
deal i'm like yeah it didn't really
affect me that way i didn't feel like i
just fell and broke my arm you know what
i mean like it
was it was much more like i went through
like an emotional period in recovery
you do like it you know oh yeah man and
like people that have
been injured understand it all the
therapists understand it
but a lot of people just go like what
are you talking about i'm like i don't
know how to explain it to you man but
it was a very mentally and emotionally
taxing time and i didn't expect it i
mean i didn't expect to get injured
and then i didn't expect it to affect me
in that way and you know like you feel a
lot of things like
one of the things that stood out to me
was like day one in the hospital
i felt like tremendous gratitude like
overwhelming i don't mean when you're
like well i'm grateful for my like i
felt like
overwhelming gratitude that that i was
in the position i was in
that my friend like bert was with me and
i i felt like
so much gratitude that he was my friend
and the whole thing was like this
it's this overwhelming experience and
like i don't know how to really
describe it to people but you know if
you're [ __ ] around playing basketball
and you think you're having fun and then
all of a sudden you feel like you got
shot like that's when i feel like i got
shot man like my [ __ ] patellar tendon
rips in half and then i land on my arm
and snap
like all of a sudden your whole world is
upside down
i mean it's it's one of those things
where it's like it's one of those
life experiences where i know this will
be like this moment
where 20 years from now you could ask me
about it and i'll be like
man that was a day that i felt like made
a huge
impact on my life you know it's like it
reminded me i was telling someone i go
you know when i was 19 i od and i was in
a coma
and it was like it was really wild
experience
and you know it's a fresh in my mind
like it doesn't
it's 20 years more than 20 years ago but
it changed the way that i was living my
life at the time i was a freshman in
college
i was doing the things that a lot of
people were doing was your freshman in
college you're experimenting with drugs
and
i was and i was like slowly escalating
right and as i was escalating you have
something real crazy happen
which is like an od and you're in and
you're in the in a coma and you're in
icu
it makes you kind of go like what the
[ __ ] am i doing right and
it changed me like i ended up never
doing
a hard drug again because it's traumatic
and so for this thing it's a totally
different thing obviously
but it just kind of affects you
in a way where you're like oh man like i
didn't realize i was this vulnerable
you know what i mean like why would i
think that i'm gonna go to jump and my
[ __ ] body's gonna break in half like
you don't think that you know and then
yeah then you feel like
this weird gratitude stuff and then i
mean i don't know man i was just in this
recovery center people are taking care
of you i was talking to a therapist
about it i'm like i don't know why this
is so
emotional for me and she's like well you
know this is kind of like
it's kind of like being a baby again
when you're when you're totally
vulnerable
as an adult and i was like trying i was
like what she goes well
you're an adult but you need someone to
help you with everything
right now like when you're when you're
fresh in there like you can't sit up on
your own
you can't eat on your own horrible you
can't do anything horrible
and people are taking care of you and
all of a sudden you go
oh i like people are taking care of me
and it kind of feels like
it sounds weird right but it feels like
you're a baby
and then these are all like your mommies
and daddies and
it just [ __ ] it [ __ ] it sat with me
man it [ __ ] did
and then i go i don't want that to
happen again
i don't want to even though i was you
know
i was working out five days a week when
i got hurt
i mean i was 30 pounds heavier than i am
now but i wasn't like
sitting around doing nothing you know
but i go like oh i can't [ __ ] around
at that weight anymore that's what i
told myself i was like you got to get
leaner and stronger because
look look at what can happen you know so
i've just taken it seriously since i
left there you know i eat clean
i work out and i just [ __ ] i don't
want to [ __ ] break [ __ ] again man
tom i refuse to watch
the video for a few weeks and i gotta be
honest with you when i watched it
between me and you
and people watching yeah i teared up
really i teared yeah you might you know
it it's
like i just thought about the pandemic
and what you were going through and i
thought about your wife and your kids
and
yeah then i saw the [ __ ] you called
me the one day we were talking on
facetime and you were with the therapist
yeah with the pt yeah i'm watching you
and the pt was helping me out
telling me stuff it's it's just so weird
but right
i got my surgery january 8th and i had
to sit in that
[ __ ] chair you know i mean yeah
it's an eternity you wake up you're
sitting in a chair you try not to watch
tv
yeah you know you don't watch tv you
just sit there you read
you do what you can and i remember that
after about a month
i said today is it i'm going to the gym
i went in there you know once the
stitches once they pulled the [ __ ]
metal things out whatever those things
were that kept going
when they were hitting the thing and i
was like about to faint
and i went to the gym and i'm doing my
thing and there's 135 pounds just
sitting on the bench press
you know a bar with 2 30 45 pound plates
yeah and the whole time i'm just doing
like you know maintenance [ __ ]
i'm you know doing the [ __ ] battle
ropes i'm doing [ __ ] pull-ups i'm
trying
and i go let me go over and see if i can
still bench press 145
because i used to do that like nothing
when i was a kid you know
so i walk over to it i [ __ ] get on
the bench takes me like two minutes with
the knee
i gotta sit and i crawl and i go to pick
up the [ __ ] thing and i go
i thought about your video really i
thought about the video and i go nah not
today
with my luck and what the world is doing
and after i saw the tom video
yeah this thing is going to go down like
a rocket ship the train is on the other
side of the room it's going to slide
down
and it's like one of those things where
i just talked to joey last night
what happened you didn't hear what
happened the [ __ ] weights fell on his
[ __ ] neck
the way the world is right now you can't
take a [ __ ] chance
i don't want to take a chance i got a
bike there i got a beautiful mountain
bike every day i look at that thing i'm
gonna go for a ride in there but i'm
like not really
not yet the legs are you go down to the
stationary bike at the gym
now i finally list last week i got on
the big boy bike
yeah and i'm doing that but i i just i
stopped taking chances after i saw you
i was like the world is crooked because
you had a knee replacement too
yes do you uh do you check out floors
now like when you walk
like a [ __ ] and i'm at the third
month mark and i refuse to go anywhere
because i can't shoot you man i can't
run and shoot
so if i can't run and shoot i can't you
see a westbound on the floor and you're
like oh
[ __ ] like i'll [ __ ] like hug a wall
like i'm not [ __ ] walking near
oh my god i walk like i walk like herman
munster i take like two little steps
my knees are straight i [ __ ] it is
a nightmare it really is a [ __ ]
nightmare what it does to you
you know and i had an accident like once
you have an accident with the surgery
like we all think we're ready like one
day i went and did comedy
and they brought me up on stage and
without even thinking
i picked up my right leg to get on stage
and that just ripped my i.t muscle
i got on the stage and i felt my whole
body rattled
like i was about to pass out i had a
pain pill in my pocket i'm like i don't
want to take a pain pill in front of him
i mean what the [ __ ] do you do and i
proceeded to do the comedy and i could
feel the leg
the bone that's how much pressure like
it just
the whole leg uh two weeks later i went
to the doctor and they told me i ripped
the [ __ ] i.t
and then you know and i was like i've
done everything i could do
[ __ ] it how's the wife good man right
i miss telling the dirty stories and
[ __ ] watching the glasses get [ __ ] up
and she misses you we [ __ ] we're like
we're really like we're you know i've
been here
almost 20 years and she's been here for
basically her whole life
and we're both like ready to go it's
it's like
it's we're excited man so she's um
you know i never thought that i could
get her out of here because i would
i would routinely go like hey would you
ever live and she's like are you are you
crazy like she would just tell me like
no
like we're not moving like and you know
if your wife's like there's no way i'm
doing this you're like
all right so that would come up all the
time and she would always shoot it down
and then it shifted where she became the
driving force
she was like i couldn't believe it we're
talking about like a lifelong resident
here
but now she's fired up man and she's
like she's doing the road so she's happy
to be doing stand-up again
you know we're obviously podcasting all
the time but she
is ready to go what is her motivator
what
what ma what did she see i think she saw
la really change especially in this last
year like
this city list i i don't know if you
remember this or not
but i've always been the la advocate
like when you travel
and people talk [ __ ] i'd be like [ __ ]
you then don't come to like i liked
la i always have and in this last year
i'm like
yo this city has gone to [ __ ] man so
it's just something that i've seen it's
it you you can't deny it
you can't act like it's not happening if
you live here
you just see it like it's it's gotten
dirty
there's [ __ ] trash everywhere there's
a homeless epidemic
it is not like when people go i live in
this city and there's home
it is there's an epidemic happening here
man where
it's not being addressed it's just
growing
and this it's been poorly managed and
dealt with and
at a certain point you go and part of
this is the pandemic too you're like
wait why am i like do i have to live
here because we always thought we had to
live here
like we're comedians would you parties
like oh you can live anywhere be a
comedian
and then you're like i'm a podcaster you
can live anywhere be a podcaster
and then you know we all kind of jump in
and out of uh
tv film stuff but you're like man it's
not the main thing i do
and i don't know like i can still do it
i can still get on a plane if i need to
to go somewhere
i love the idea you know for me most of
my life is touring
and it's like i would much rather tour
from the middle of the country
than what i've been doing which is
flying out of the southwest
corner of the country every [ __ ]
house makes a big difference
no more four-hour flights it's two
you're two three and a half two and a
half hours from anywhere right now from
austin great airport you're right in the
middle of the country you know all right
for me
my wife started pushing this campaign in
2016.
in 2016 we went we came to jersey for
the holidays
and my wife was like i don't know what
you're waiting for to pull the [ __ ]
trigger
yeah i went to woodland hills i looked
at three houses
like in 2015 and i was like
no to all three i don't wanna i knew in
2015
i didn't want to buy i'm like i'm not
looking to buy it
to spend 900 thousand dollars on a house
that's worth 450 000
yeah so that was very good that i was
smart enough to see that
i came here in 2016 with her and on the
way home
at the airport she goes i don't know why
we're even going back
and then it was two years of just and i
think after i shot the netflix special
with christina yeah
that whole experience [ __ ] me up bro
really i didn't like it i didn't like
how it went down
i didn't think that it was uh you know
2 000 stages in vegas and we're doing it
at a [ __ ] pool
yeah you know and then strange the
[ __ ] the wall came crashing down
i didn't like what you know i just
didn't
i didn't train right for it nothing that
i did was right on that whole
situation that plane ride home was a
deep
deep [ __ ] thought process for me
yeah and i said i don't know what or how
i'm gonna get the [ __ ] out of here but
it was just all downhill after that
you know i was i look at those old
podcasts and my everything has changed
about me my face
my train of thought you know i just kept
going into a deeper
deeper emotional hole and i was fueling
it with the edibles and then the
pandemic hit
and it was the [ __ ] footballs and it
was just
you know no alcohol no no nothing
bad but basically during the pandemic
from
apr from april to june i basically did
edibles to pass out at night
yeah and i would destroy the kitchen the
kitchens were destroyed in the mornings
my wife would tell me
it was just a rough time and then once
july
12th came and they announced there was
no school
my daughter was struggling i'm not
ashamed to say that
those four months at home killed her
she's a [ __ ]
social butterfly yeah so they [ __ ]
killed her
and uh when i saw that there was no
school the whole year i was like we're
out of here
that was that was the pushing point for
me was i think you made the right choice
man
yeah no i know from my for my health
my family my daughter we made the right
choice
you know uh tv and film you could do
anywhere now
there's something about this year too
because i haven't left yet
where basically you're like oh because
you you see things stripped down like
everything's stripped down
you can see things kind of more clearly
so it's like
the basically what i enjoy is
pulling into my house you know i mean
like
i like my house physically i like the
neighborhood
and i like seeing my family and i'm like
oh but like when i once i leave like
when i pull out onto the street here
immediately i'm like ah [ __ ] like you
know i mean like i'm kind of aggravated
why but it's just like the the
surroundings the chaos
like i just go it's too much there's
like there's i don't i'm not enjoying
driving to my office to do like it's not
it's not enjoyable then i go like
i feel like i live in like a mad max
kind of world
and i go i don't what's the upside
like for me to staying here like what
what's the
what's my explanation for why i live
here and why i like living here like i
live here because i've lived here
but to continue living here i'm like i
don't know man i just don't feel like
i don't feel like it does anything for
me you know what i mean like it's like
there's a there's a point where you go
like what
what's the excitement where's the you
know like
what's the thrill and i wasn't doing
anything for me either at the end time
yeah at the end it was we would just
repeat play
go to lax come back it was a [ __ ]
repeat and play zone
you know yeah and i do feel that thrill
and when i was in i've been in austin
like 10 times
in the last couple of months man i
really dig the city
i i love the house i got i
i don't know i'm excited like it's fun
to feel excited about
where you're gonna live and i i feel
like i don't know i feel like it's it's
the right move for me man i'm really i'm
excited about it
when you went down there austin is
welcoming you [ __ ] in
oh yeah like they're they're uh ecstatic
about this
you know and the people there are
different man like
they you know there's great people
everywhere so i don't like the blanket
generalization that like but still
most people are like that like they're
they're just friendlier they
you know they they say hi no one says hi
in la people don't know that but there
is no like
good morning or like how's it going
that's a very
weird thing to adapt to like when i got
here i was like oh people don't do that
they don't say like how you doing you
people be like what like la
is not a how you doing kind of place dog
i went from jersey
to colorado where people tell you good
morning
yeah and the first month i would go home
every day and tell my roommates well is
everybody [ __ ] gay in this town
i had a guy just say good morning to me
wanted to suck my dick i thought people
wanted to suck my dick
and rape me and [ __ ] cause they were
saying good morning to me i'm from new
york where nobody [ __ ] says nothing
to you yeah they don't even make eye
contact
and colorado then people actually not
just just say good morning
but stop yeah and want to talk to you
i'm 19. i'm like i don't want to talk to
you
no i don't [ __ ] know you so how long
have you been here none of your [ __ ]
business
keep [ __ ] walking what's with the
questions what are you a private
investigator
like i swear to god you know what part
of jersey who cares you don't know where
it is anyway
you know what i'm saying what are you
asking me for you don't know what the
[ __ ] it is anyway
just keep walking i mean i was that
shell shocked
as a kid when i got to california i
thought people were very
listen i for me to look at you and tell
you i don't miss living there
it's a complete lie i miss okay certain
things
yeah there were certain things i really
do miss about california
for my family's future there was nothing
there right
there was nothing there you know i had
two three years left at the store
maybe and then you're a [ __ ] old
[ __ ] dinosaur
down there amongst a bunch of young kids
you look like a [ __ ] jerk off
you know and i didn't want to do that i
i
i'm having a great time taking time off
from comedy
tom segura this started from in 91 for
me
that's a long time you know right now 30
years ago i was working at a door as a
doorman at a comedy club
that's wild you know chappelle's been
doing it
yeah chappelle's been doing it longer
when i started
writing jokes in 93 chappelle was
already a star
with robin hood and men in tights so
but chappelle took a bunch of years off
yeah you know he took a big chunk off in
the middle there
you know that's a nobody and then he
came back stronger than ever
that's what i'm trying to do that's what
i'm trying to explain to people that
for me every night i look at the clock
at a quarter to eight
and i go do i want to get dressed and go
to one of the local comedy clubs and see
russell peters was here sam triply's
been here
there's been 10 comics of my friends
that have come through here
i have not gone to see one of them for
me i had to pull myself away from comedy
yeah like i had to just pull myself away
from stand-up podcasting
i love doing i love talking to you
[ __ ] at first it was a little
hard trying to pull the bill burr
by yourself that's a [ __ ] nightmare
podcast [ __ ] that man but i'm starting
to get better at it i like it
just pick a subject rant for 45 minutes
and you know
talk to the people connect with them let
them know what you're going through and
get the [ __ ] out of there i didn't want
to smoke
dope anymore i didn't want to cross come
across as an old edible [ __ ] guy
i look at some of those old podcasts
with a t-shirt on
they were just disgusting they were
disgusting
when we moved out of that office that
[ __ ] carpet
was just drug induced yeah i'm sure you
all you had to do it
all you had to do is walk in there and
sit for five minutes and the drugs would
rise off the carpet
everything was in there my mahogany
juice [ __ ] thc
ketamine we did everything but coke in
that [ __ ] thing
yeah every drug was done no no heroin
either
i mean but it was acid acid on a sugar
cone
hash under a glass you know i have a new
hour that i'm working out right now
and um a big chunk is uh i have a big
bit about you and me and miami that's
that's like a a big bit
in the new hour that was i didn't sleep
that night
i didn't sleep at all that night you
took [ __ ] like a thousand milligrams
bro
i kept popping them you know this is
what i'm talking about i was maniac
i was [ __ ] out of control
but you know the funny thing is though
this is the funny thing and i talk about
this sometimes
about you is that people that are around
you
like me other comedians
we don't think like we go holy [ __ ]
that's a lot
but we don't realize that you're [ __ ]
up
you know i mean like we're like i guess
he just
is fine like i had to ask you one time i
was like
do you not get [ __ ] up and you're like
i just had three panic attacks and i was
like oh okay
because i was like you seem like it's
not affecting you and you're like oh no
it's totally [ __ ] up i was like oh
okay but your tolerance was just my
tolerance was so
it was getting to the point where i
would eat like 100
milligram capsule and i would be high
for two hours
and then i'd give a capsule to you and
you'd call me
after a four-hour flight six hours later
you're still [ __ ] high and i'm like
something's not right yeah man you had
me [ __ ] up i'm not kidding you
i took a pill from you
on uh 12 15. no
earlier oh you know i took it like
before your 10 o'clock show so like 9
30 i took that pill i was
[ __ ] i was completely out of my mind
for let's say 16 18 hours but i was
still
high that night the following night and
the next morning
i was like hungover so i was pretty much
[ __ ] up for like 30 hours
you know and you were like you were on
ten times the amount joshua
said he ate two of them one night and he
was driving back from sandia he goes he
was gonna do the show in san diego and
drive back
he said he went to his room and he goes
i'm just gonna lay down on this bed
for two minutes and get my composure
before i get in the car
he said he woke up the next morning in
that position like he was dead
with his arms up he goes he just opened
his eyes and he looked down he had his
sneakers on
the light was on the tv you know what we
never talked about
we never talked about this when i came
to see you so i did my show and i came
to see you
i drove across town after and i go to
your show
i had mike cronin who's another comedian
with me
and you had told us you know these are
tens
and so i took mine and then i go
you know he's with me he's a comic i go
can i give
mike one you're like yeah so i'm like
you want one he goes yeah so he took it
now for whatever reason for our own body
composition
i get [ __ ] up like pretty quickly
like within within two hours i know that
i'm completely [ __ ]
and you and i we leave
and when i leave mike's not he's not
[ __ ] up so he goes i thought he goes i
just thought tom you were just such a
lightweight because i was like
i can't believe he's [ __ ] up it didn't
hit you know you know edibles like
sometimes they hit people at a different
time right
so when i left i also remember thinking
like i can't believe i'm this [ __ ] up
and mike is like sober he's like fine
so you and i leave and we get on our
flight to go home
i'm [ __ ] up you know for the next
whatever like two days
well after that i finally call mike and
i go uh
hey man yeah i mean so did that not
affect you he goes
dude he goes you guys left and i go wow
tom's such a lightweight
i go back to the hotel and he goes
it starts to hit me i end up
sleeping on the bathroom floor
next to the toilet telling myself
not to jump off the building because i
kept hearing at something saying you
need to jump off the balcony
and i go what he goes dude i
thought i was gonna kill myself and i
was like holy [ __ ] and he goes
then i i wake up the next morning like
you said i wake up
in the bathroom on the floor sleeping on
the marble floor
because i get in the car and i have to
drive he's in miami he has to drive to
his parents place in tampa
he goes i'm [ __ ] up the whole way the
whole drive
and when i get there it's evening
my parents are having dinner so i sit
down for dinner and he goes
i have dinner with them and i can't
really talk i'm still like
just too [ __ ] up so then i go to my
room and he goes and my mom
texts me is everything okay you're not
you're not you don't seem like yourself
so it [ __ ] him up for like two days
too it just started like two hours later
so think about that it was if it was
[ __ ] people up for two days
yeah it was [ __ ] me up for two hours
that's crazy
that's just that's not that's not normal
no that's not normal and i
know but we all were like joey's not
normal and i'm ashamed
and and you know so i gave you the
edible
you called me at lunchtime and i could
tell there was a little anger in your
voice
oh yeah and then that night rogan calls
me and he's like
what'd you do to tom doug and he's the
one he's like this shit's gotta end
i'm getting too many complaints about
you people are freaking out
he goes you gotta stop and then we
started laughing together
like as he was telling me the story he
was like you can't do that to tom he's
your brother
i go he was fine like it was a [ __ ]
10 milligrams seems like it's not
10 it's a hundred there were two
hundreds
but my take from that night my
the best part of that night was after i
got off stage
i'm fired up you know when you go you
got to imagine when you go on stage
all that [ __ ] disappears from my world
you
[ __ ] i'll say this you [ __ ]
murdered
now you are murdered now think about
that
think about what i had in my body and
what i went on stage and did
it disappears when i go on stage it's
wild
it disappears i had a i was in such an
animal mode
as a stand-up that i had to tame myself
back sometimes
and the only way i knew by doing it was
by taking 600 milligrams you got to
remember
one thing and this is my secret and i'm
giving it to the world now i think i
told it before
before i would leave for the comedy
store
i'd do four cups of cuban coffee
four cuban espressos you're not gonna
stop that
i would do one of those at eight fifteen
a four show up ready to go i'm showing
up ready to rip your [ __ ] head off
i'm showing up on the when you drink
that much espresso and you have that
much caffeine in your system cuban style
with no cold no sugar i won't put sugar
in it i just drink it
like that strong you're on you're
already teetering
on blowing up your anxiety yeah when you
drink that strength of coffee
at one shot like that you're already
teetering
at that anxiety level so while i'm
driving down the hill to the commie
store
my head's already [ __ ] flying i'm
[ __ ] flying so i would have to take
an edible
to tame the animal down 400 milligrams
you know i just became you know for me
to
do that on stage i got to do that all
day
yeah i got to be at that rpm all day
revving
when i get up at [ __ ] seven in the
morning and it was my dick is in my hand
and i'm pissing
i'm already thinking about that spot
tonight
and who's going to follow me and who i'm
following and
you know what i need to do to make that
you know i was telling people the other
day on here
i got a bunch of emails from people you
got to go back on the road i got no
material
i can't even think of [ __ ] material
right now
if you want i'll go out there
pop two edibles and just go up there and
be silly and charge you 40 bucks
i'll rip you [ __ ] you forgot
these people forget i'm a natural thief
i'm a thief from the jump if you want me
to go out there and just talk [ __ ] on
stage for an hour i'll talk about the
bay of pigs
that's what i do when i'm in a tight
spot with the when i was a kid whenever
the cops would [ __ ] [ __ ] with me i'd
talk about the bear pigs
and the cops would go like what you just
like
this guy's on the floor and you're
talking about the bay of pigs and
the atrocities they did in cuba and
kennedy's and [ __ ]
i'll just go off on that [ __ ] for an
hour if you want i want to be on stage
and i want to be the best i could be
from
just like when you're on stage i saw
that you do that when you go out you put
tickets on
working out with tom that means don't
expect dick
yeah when you give me 20 don't expect
dick
you're gonna get point is like yeah
you're gonna get in my mind you're gonna
get pieces of my mind and me working on
the material
when i ask you for 25 i'm at 80 percent
when i ask you for 30
you better crazy cool your [ __ ]
toupee because i'm in business to blow
that [ __ ] off if you show up
with
what's his name from goodfellas what's
maury
that [ __ ] better have duct tape
on that wig because i'm gonna blow it
out that's what i go on stage to do i
don't go on stage to be mediocre
who wants to be mediocre i want to go on
stage and
[ __ ] you up from the beginning to the
end i want you to feel something
i either want you to hate me or love me
at the end that's fe
even if you hate me you're feeling
something i did my job yeah i did my job
totally true so you know that's where
i'm at
that that's where the [ __ ] i meant so
that's why i was at that
at that level now i'm so interesting to
hear
you like kind of reflect on this because
i've never i never knew any of this
insight
about your approach or like what you
know what the edibles were doing and
balancing it out with the like the
the caffeine and like i i just never
assumed it i just figured
you were this a guy that likes to get
high you know i mean
but there's actually more there's more
to it no i
listen man i was raised catholic i was
raised to be a nerd
one day i went off the beaten path when
i was 12 or 13
and i smoked pot and i realized that it
was the answer to all the problems i had
my anxiety
my insecurities it elevated me a little
bit
and i enjoyed what it did to me i really
liked the ride i didn't like alcohol
cocaine was a pain thing my main thing
always was reefer since the age of
i think i committed to marijuana at 16
without alcohol
yeah like i i think i thought when you
drank with reefer
you ruined it so
yeah i loved weed i loved weed
until this one point like i stopped i
smoked
in college i would say pretty much every
day
and then i got here and it was the same
and we would do just bomb rips like in
in our apartment
and then i remember one day i can't like
specify the exact
incident but i remember having like a
tremendous anxiety episode
and it really put me off but what ended
up happening was like i just
didn't smoke for a while but then the
next time i smoked
my tolerance had gone down so far
that it was like another anxiety episode
so i kind of avoided it
you know i mean like for a while like in
my
late 20s early 30s i mean i would do it
like sporadically but
i just felt like so anxious every time i
smoked
and now i haven't really smoked in a
long time but i
keep doing the mild edibles because it
kind of gives me that buzz that i like
and that it helps me with going to sleep
but it's not too strong
where i feel fully [ __ ] panicked you
know i'll tell you what i've been
working with lately
because i experiment you know me i'm a
[ __ ] scientist
yeah so what i've been doing about a
week ago
my peep sent me a tincture it's a
thousand milligrams
in this bottle do you know i was putting
half the bottle in my [ __ ] tea
some nights but i thought about
something you know felicia michaels has
crohn's disease
okay and she had a doctor that was a
stomach doctor what do you call those
oncologists or whatever
i know that's a gastroenterologist
gastro so i can't even say the word i'm
not even gonna bother
so i was talking to him her one night
and we were talking about smoke and
reefer and she goes she gave up
eight years ago for two reasons she her
lungs
and she's a runner you know she didn't
wanna
and i go so what do you do to get high
and she goes i got the best high in the
world and she gave me a tincture
she put it with club soda and
she goes you're gonna get [ __ ] up
after about two hours i'm like this
lady's [ __ ]
i knew this [ __ ] wasn't gonna work and i
gotta tell you something about three
hours later it hit me like a [ __ ] ton
of bricks
so i've been taking that same thing and
instead of wasting in the tea
i put it under my tongue uh-huh
and brother within the hour it's not be
no no time
really in a big [ __ ] way that's
why i don't wake up at night no more
i use these glasses to sleep these uh
goggles these uh blue blocks goggles
yeah
you put them behind your head and it
blacks out everything
i have been sleeping like a baby
for the last month i you know for years
i didn't
whenever i would gain weight i knew it
was because i'm not sleeping
yeah mondays wednesdays i was doing that
podcast
thursday i was getting up at four to go
to [ __ ] a city
and friday i was doing radio in that
city at four in the morning five
six you know you're off your [ __ ]
schedule i would
even if i drink water i would gain five
pounds that weekend
yeah and i would [ __ ] bang my head
and go i didn't eat dessert i didn't do
this i didn't do that
dude do you know that the biggest weight
gain that i probably went through
was when i started featuring nationally
like
like traveling to feature week after
week
because my i like you i wouldn't sleep
you're making no money so you're like
stressed out
and you're still doing like you know
they make you still do like press and
all this [ __ ] and like i would gain like
30 pounds in a year that was it that was
what i was doing
if you don't [ __ ] sleep for a guy
like me it just [ __ ] up a ton of things
but
you look good man yeah yeah dawg i've
been working on this this is something
when i go back on the road i'm going to
be ready in more ways than one
i want to be awesome take care of
yourself now
get ready for it so when are you in
austin officially may 10th
may 10th officially yeah and what's the
rest of the year look like for you
i mean right now i'm i'm i'm going back
to you know i'm doing
clubs i'm doing spanish and english
shows right now stand up
why don't you podcast and then depending
on how the next like
um six weeks shapes out i'm either going
to announce
a tour in the fall that i was i've been
planning for a while
um you know depending on like vaccine
pandemic status
we're i think we're going to announce it
because things are starting to open up
so things are really opening up now and
now
with this case out of the way this this
was a big plus you know however you want
to look at it yeah
whatever was going on in minneapolis you
know that moved on
so i think we're good to go i think that
uh we're good to go
you know you got to wear your
bulletproof vest you gotta wear your
bulletproof [ __ ] suit with your
helmet just in case somebody shoots but
listen you gotta live your life no
matter what's going on out there the
pandemic actually
[ __ ] a lot of people up and [ __ ] me
up i'm not
ashamed to admit it but we're here today
we're looking good we're moving forward
and that's all that matters i'm going to
come to austin in september
uh coming over i'm coming over i already
made plans with bert
i talked to him before he went to
[ __ ] how much what are you drinking
serbia
what are they drinking in serbia right
now i mean well he's he's facetimed me
twice with
huge glasses of wine so i think he's
drinking wine
[Laughter]
i love you in all my heart thank you
very much for
uh doing this i miss you with all my
heart
i never meant to doshu even though uh i
apologize to you
i got you back with this bit don't you
worry about it okay and then uh
i just want to remind you of the trip we
took that time
and we were in the [ __ ]
eugene oregon airport and [ __ ]
people are coming up to us and you and
me are freaking out that was
and i still remember what we were
talking about the racist rant i went on
that day about [ __ ]
nobody will ever know i remember doing
rogan
and i was just after that week and i was
telling the story to go he said
he goes say it i go i can't say it and
he goes we're cause we're on mike he
goes say i go there's no way i can
repeat this
and i'll say what it was today i saw a
little chinese girl with like a six foot
six
black dude and i'm like what is he doing
to a [ __ ] i mean what the [ __ ]
damage he's destroying the whole ying
dynasty
like he's setting back the ming dynasty
two thousand years with that big black
dick
i think about that conversation all the
time this
last week you know every morning you
wake up you open up social media
and your dad made the mistake like i
usually go on yahoo first then hotmail i
have a system
then twitter and then you warm yourself
up for facebook because that's the worst
the other day i did i did the whole
system and i'm like what am i going to
see on twitter if somebody got shot
i click up and it's a white shake
sucking a dick
that had to be 19 inches and it went
crooked
like it was like a [ __ ] sign she's
munching on that dick and i'm like
you know your life is [ __ ] up it's 7
30 in the morning when you wake up
you open up twitter and the chicks got
18 inches of black
i mean this dick was thick too you
also talked about you said you know that
jameis winston [ __ ] that chick
you know they you know she couldn't stop
coming back for that cocoa butter
and like you went on about james winston
i don't even know who the [ __ ] james
winston is he was a he was a quarterback
he was
he was florida state's quarterback at
the time he was in the news because some
girl accused him of some like sexual
thing and you were like she wanted that
[ __ ]
you were saying crazy [ __ ] man and i was
so high i was like shut up
shut the [ __ ] up now you know why i
don't eat edibles anymore
yeah my best to your family my best to
you and your beautiful wife my best to
your kids
thanks and i'll see you in september in
austin bro yeah
send my best to your family too buddy i
love you guys
i want to show you one thing yeah
the cabin oh the cabin yeah with bird
yeah i gotta fill the [ __ ] reefer
nice it's what the [ __ ]
i love you guys man oh please i'm still
the same guy
you know what this is here keith
everybody thinks joey what the [ __ ] is
this you got a thing full of pills
this is keith to make [ __ ] the best
brownies in the world
when i make them i'll send them to you
down in austin you'll see the devil
you're coming to the house man i love
you have a great week
all right buddy you too stay black all
right you bad [ __ ] i hope you
enjoyed that little interview with tom
segura you know it is what it is uh
we're zooming for a few new weeks we got
a couple [ __ ]
surprises coming up for you by the way
my patreon i don't know what's going on
with patreon i've been hearing across
the board
uh as of today the [ __ ] messaging
something is off
with the messages it doesn't let me
greet people on patreon when you sign up
uh i hope patreon is taking care of the
problem
and uh tomorrow i have a call
with the nft people uh so i'll know more
about the nfts to incorporate them in
patreon
and that's it you bad [ __ ] i
got no dates
i got no worries i got no problems all i
got is
uh love for you [ __ ] and uh
i'm grateful to have you guys i'm
grateful that you still watch
and i'm grateful that this whole [ __ ]
thing is over and we can get our lives
back to work
and in time i'll bump into one of you
[ __ ] along the line
and uh say hello maybe hopefully you
know i was watching major league the
other night
and i'm like boy do i miss [ __ ]
cleveland man i really miss cleveland so
uh trust me this will be over for me
quicker than what it is i'm one of those
[ __ ]
that one day i wake up and i go today's
the [ __ ] day and i attack it
but anyway thank you guys very much
happy cinco de mayo don't get too [ __ ]
up
have a great weekend and we'll be back
monday morning
tip top [ __ ] magoo now for a
word for my [ __ ] sponsors jack
all right i want to thank you guys for
listening to tom segura
some of you is [ __ ] bailed some of
you is listening whatever
i don't care guess what the only thing i
cared about is i showed the [ __ ] up
that's the most important thing
i love you for showing up also but let's
get this party started
the joint is brought to you by blue
blocks i've already told you
about blue blocks amazing sleep mass and
now i'm here to tell you
about their light filtering glasses
they're [ __ ] tremendous
you get any style color or size plus
they got the virtual try on on the
website you can't get that anywhere else
i've never seen that before
and i love it first you got sleep plus
red lenses
for true blue and green light blocking
use it after sundown if you have trouble
sleeping or get anxious at night
these are for you then we got your clear
blue light lens
filter blue light during the day if you
spend all day in front of the computer
these are for you go to the website and
take a look at all the different pairs
of sunglasses they have
with clear blue light lens you'll die
cut down on headaches and eye strain and
finally
they got summer glow yellow lenses color
therapy
for the winter blues clinically proven
to lift your mood
plus you get all these benefits of blue
light blocking listen to me
i love this company i love what they're
doing ever since i've been used
i use their glasses at night when i'm on
the computer and i gotta tell you
something
i sleep a lot easier and then i go
upstairs without the michael jackson t
and i put the blue blocks
sleep plus on the mask and i sleep like
a baby you understand me
no lighting no nothing you don't know
what's going on it's tremendous blue
blocks
is a science-based company that lenses
are made
under optics laboratory conditions in
australia
you got a prescription no problem don't
make it to your specifications
these are high quality lenses not mass
produced
and they come in a ton of styles from
glasses to sleep masks
they've got everything you're going to
need for light therapy
and the service is magnifique go to
their website right now go to
blueblocks.com right now
and so you know why because they support
this show but i'm also
going to get you 20 off with code joey
at blueblocks.com
joey again that's blueblox.com
joey for 20 off blueblox.com
joey i want to thank blue blocks glasses
i want to thank cbd lion
and i want to thank draftkings do not
forget about the big fight this week
use code joey better dollar and you win
55
you can't [ __ ] win that anywhere else
and
i want to remind you about this annual
semi-annual sale
and on it on everything 50 off
kettlebell i mean everything
no promo codes will work they're gonna
just just go to on it
and drop some [ __ ] either she's been
looking for those kettlebells
and the club bats and everything else i
want to thank you guys for always
supporting
and having my back i love you
[ __ ] have a great cinco de mayo
stay safe and i'll see you [ __ ]
monday next week
tip top [ __ ] magoo i love yous
[ __ ] stay black
there you go
so
so
so
[Music]
so
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
you